take us all the way back to to the point
of which you are sat on the other side
of the desk
from where you are right now receiving
that diagnosis
so it was actually during my colonoscopy
that they push in the little bit of
sedation so
that you should relax and you lie back
and i glanced at the television screen
and saw something that was very very
clearly abnormal and
i turned around and looked at the
surgeon and
basically what's that and as his eyes
came up to make mine
i knew and the room got quieter and
quieter and everyone got kinder and
kinder and as they did
for me the worse it got because
essentially i had come to that
realization that it was
cancer on my own and just like that your
entire world
changes because while cancer tries to
take over your body it also tries to
take away
all the other things that you do be that
work or parenthood or
or friendship everything becomes about
cancer and it was really important to me
to be able to hold on
to something and for me that's always
been and i know it's a cliche to say
that you're a doctor because you want to
help people but for me that was
always sort a presiding aim
what what i puzzle over philippa is
whether or not
you you being a doctor made things
better or worse
obviously you're immediately able to
identify something as abnormal which
most of us would
would not be able to do but did your
knowledge of oncology did your knowledge
of bowel cancer
i mean did that make you feel even worse
than you presumably were or or did it at
least allow you
the ability to know what your doctor was
talking about in terms of treatment
plans
so there are pros and cons so i
understand medical ease i understand the
medical language
and i feel comforted when people use
that because that's my language so there
are pros
but there are real cons in that whilst i
always believe knowledge is power
doctors are taught
to think about the next steps what
happens if this doesn't work what
happens if that doesn't work and so
i've been in intensive care with things
going wrong and some part of my brain is
still
thinking in a very magical way someone
better come in and give me an infusion
of this drug or that drug and that
fights with the patient
who is just simply scared and so there
are pros and cons but i think that also
it's affected me how i am as a doctor
and that's because i realize now more
than ever
that not everything can be fixed and
that's okay so doctors always try to fix
even if it's just with ourselves come
back and see me next week
and actually what patients often need is
just somebody to sit
with them and say that's really tough
and i'm here
because we can do tough things it's just
it's easier to do than when we feel
supported and not alone
does that does that not perhaps make
your job even more difficult i know
i know a number of medics of my
acquaintance but they're largely in
hospital settings
and there is an almost invisible wall
sometimes
even pre-pandemic up between them and
the people that they treat the you know
they're in and out in and out and
all day long but but as a general
practitioner that that emotional
connection
with your patients perhaps is more
is more possible and certainly more
obvious
so i think that doctors are taught to
not give of themselves because if we
give of ourselves
always there will be nothing left for us
and so we do
have a wall but patients really
appreciate the human
and they really want to see that
sometimes and so it's about striking the
balance between
giving enough that patients feel
listened to
and feel that you understand them while
still protecting yourself and actually i
think that that's something that we need
to be teaching medical students much
more because the difficulties with the
wall versus the human
are essentially why one of the reasons
why we think so many doctors have mental
health problems because it
is such a difficult balance but patients
really do seem to appreciate
the fact that i truly understand now of
course it's still about them it's not
about me
but just knowing that somebody gets it
can make real difference
i'm philippa how are you doing at the
moment
so i had a hopping surgery in the
pandemic
in september and at the end of that i
was told thankfully that i
am cancer-free and that was one of the
real drives to publish the book
was that we have this image in our heads
of cancer being the beginning of the end
and 50
of us are going to get cancer at some
point but more and more of us are
surviving it and it seemed
really important to deliver that message
of hope but the truth is i have my first
set of scans and scopes at the end of
this month
and like any patient with cancer i'm
pretty terrified
yeah i can i can well i can't imagine
because i'm not in your position but
i i certainly sympathize with it if you
had a message though
to people in uh perhaps concerned about
aspects of their health
concerned about being a burden on people
like yourself
gps what would you say to them
the nhs is open i have the only job
where people
knock on my door come in and say i'm so
sorry to bother you doc my whole job
is for you to bother me the nhs is open
waiting will not help because when when
it comes to cancer time matters the
earlier you are diagnosed
better your prognosis is likely to be
two week breaks expected cancer clinics
are still open so if you have any
concerns about your health please please
contact your gp
the book is called doctors get cancer
too dr philippa kay thanks so much for
joining us in the program